let's start today looking at some of the
most important and key races coming up
now as we are just about eight weeks
away
from the 2022 midterm elections now
we've looked generally at how things are
shaping up meaning in general
democrats have a likely shot at holding
the senate and it is most likely that
republicans are going to take the house
of representatives but to really
understand kind of the texture of what's
going on we have to go beyond just the
top line numbers and really look at some
specific races and unfortunately while
there is quite a bit of good news if you
look at the specific races some of the
specific races that we've been covering
there is
i mean i can't really call it anything
other than extraordinarily disturbing
polling data
showing that this is a really messed up
country i mean there there's sometimes
you know we want to come up with the
most sophisticated and detailed and
nuanced way of looking at a situation in
the in the political world but
it's just things are really screwed up
because of some really messed up people
and let's start with sort of like what's
okay and then we'll get into what's not
looking quite so good so all right in
pennsylvania in the senate there's this
very important race television dr mehmet
oz versus the democratic lieutenant
governor john fetterman
fetterman is extraordinarily smart
uh extraordinarily qualified has logical
consistent positions on issues and is a
great candidate on the other hand you
have television dr mehmet oz who has
taken every side of all issues masks
of vaccines um
cures
abortion whatever
um isn't even really from pennsylvania
although you know it's for pennsylvania
voters to decide whether that's
something that they care about if it's i
mean listen there would be candidates
that are so good that if they moved to
some new state on day one and on day two
said i'm running i would vote for them
so it's up to pennsylvanians to decide
whether they care about the that
um and is just completely unqualified
and the good news is that on average
fetterman is leading polls by six and a
half as you can see here
the bad news is that
fetterman's only leading by six and a
half so like when we look at this is
this good or is this bad well it would
be worse if oz was leading
but this should be a 30-point blowout a
40-point blowout if the world made sense
another example also in pennsylvania
this one's really important governor's
race doug mastriano a
big lie proponent
an attendee of january 6th a guy who we
know if he is governor in 2024
and a democrat wins pennsylvania
masteriano will try to steal the
pennsylvania electoral votes for the
republican disaster absolute and total
disaster
doug i'm sorry josh shapiro is winning
but only by six
by all reasonable standards the world
looks at this race and says wait a
second
you've got a completely uncontroversial
standard
reasonable
law supporting due process supporting
pro-law and order democrat
and you've got masteriano who just got
caught wearing a confederate uniform and
shapiro's only up six what is wrong with
americans and that is the correct
reaction why is he only winning by six
look at florida
in florida we've got incumbent
republican senator marco rubio being
challenged by democratic congresswoman
val demings rubio is
just one of the
he's one of the shakiest senators for
sure
um and the one
poll we have recently is from august if
you go before that you have to go all
the way back to february so the one
recent poll has val demings up four
that's good
but rubio is a humiliation to the senate
he should be getting crushed and we have
only an inkling that maybe demings has a
shot that's really disturbing
and then we have the arizona senate uh
blake masters versus mark kelly mark
kelly the democrat incumbent
smart guy
relatively progressive guy not the most
progressive a former astronaut
a thinker in in many ways
and blake masters is just a cartoonish
clown
and somehow kelly is only up by six so
it's good i mean listen it's good that
kelly is winning but only by six that's
really concerning now then we get into
the absolutely cuckoo for coco puff
stuff take a look at some of these
numbers in the georgia senate you have
the thoughtful
empathetic
intelligent incumbent democratic senator
raphael warnock being challenged by the
republican candidate former football
player herschel walker who cannot speak
he cannot speak he cannot formulate a
coherent opinion on any issue
and in the average of recent polls
warnock is leading by only one by only
one
folks walker cannot speak and he cannot
think
and raphael warnock is winning by only
one that is a georgia dystopia
also in georgia you have this
loony republican governor brian kemp
the incumbent being challenged by stacey
abrams abrams is brilliant abrams has
done more for voting expansion in
georgia over the last decade than anyone
i can think of
and kemp is winning by an average of
five points there the world is backwards
truly backwards a couple others that are
just really scary
or one more in texas you've got the
incumbent governor greg abbott who has
overseen a radical restriction of access
to abortion services family planning
he's involved in this
absolutely loony isolation of the texas
power grid and he supports it and he
defends it and he loves it
and then he is being challenged by beto
o'rourke
who i like quite a bit not the most
progressive but
very strong on guns very strong on
women's rights and abbott is leading by
an average
of about seven points consider that
republicans are truly offering
nothing right now nothing republicans
offer
obstructionism
and
we will own the libs and anger the libs
they're not even offering bad policy
they're offering no policy and yet in
some of these places the electorate the
constituents are so weaponized by
disinformation they've fallen for
whatever local version of
maga
uh
that that is prevalent
and many of them are going to win so
these numbers these data as some like to
say
are as reflective
of the sad state of american politics as
they are of this just sort of reality
that usually when one party takes the
white house in the next midterm that
party doesn't do well like that's a
general structural thing
fine
but some of these numbers i mean warnock
versus walker
just the humiliation are reflective of
the the weaponization of almost it's
like a pride
in not being about anything other than
just angering the left and that's
actually sort of working for some of
them so we'll continue looking at all
these numbers later in the week i'll
give you updated numbers on how is the
house looking how is the senate looking
and we will go from there